I became pregnant with a baby I
desperately wanted at a routine
ultrasound I learned that the fetus
would have a fatal condition and that
there was absolutely no chance of
survival in Texas you are forced to
carry that pregnancy and that is because
of Donald Trump overturning roie Wade
the choice was completely taken away I
was to continue my pregnancy putting my
life at risk it's every woman's worst
nightmare and it was absolutely
unbearable we need leaders that will
protect our rights and not take them
away and that's Joe Biden and kamla
Harris the part that's not true is that
it risked her life it didn't an Anil
does not cause life-threatening
complications and furthermore Texas
allows for abortions when the mother
faces complications that could impact
her health